And to actually get into some of the specific classes here, let's look at the kind of overview
of the six core components at the top in pink and then maybe some multiplayer networks ready
classes that are below. That's not to say that they're specifically designed for anything
networked in this instance, but it's good to be aware of these moving forward.
So thinking about a Pawn, a Pawn is the base class for any actor that can be controlled by the player
or AI. So you may be thinking about Pawn and Character if you do have familiarity with
Unreal Engine, they're very similar in nature and you'd be right in thinking that. The Pawn
specifically provides the capabilities which the controller chooses what to use and when.
So you can possess a Pawn, you can control a Pawn, but the main difference between a Pawn and a
Character is that a Character is a very specific type of Pawn that, you know, it can still walk,
run, jump and fly. It can do all the movement behavior, but the Character takes some of the heavy
lifting for you and applies it. So you may have a skeletal mesh component added to the Character
and a collision capsule and some of the things that the Pawn by default may not want. The Pawn
is like the higher level class, so, you know, it could be a vehicle, it could be a Character,
it could be a AI based component. So the Character takes a lot of what the Pawn does
and gives you some good defaults to work with. So a lot of times you may just go straight to
Character, which would be fine to do, but I just wanted to differentiate between Pawn and Character
here just to give you the high level overview. Whereas the Controller is something very different.
The Controller, think about the Controller, almost like the brain for the Pawn and the
Characters. So a player Controller is used by the player to control, you know, the Pawn or the
Character and you can receive input from the Controller to control a Pawn or a Character.
This is why I say it's almost like a brain. So the Controller will be the thing controlling
the Pawn or the Character. The Controller is spawned at runtime and not all Pawns would need
Controllers by any means because, you know, like I said, it might be an AI entity or a vehicle
or something like this, but as we get into the player Controller, you'll see where this becomes
a little bit different with actually possessing Pawns and Characters. So as we look at the player
Controller, the player Controller is receiving input from the human player controlling it.
So it's almost like a specialized Controller. It represents a human player locally in the game
and it's a central place to handle the input and the player view. So you can again then use that
to provide input to maybe your Character. So if you have a player Controller and a Character,
you might assign that Controller to the Character, again almost like acting like the
brain or something like this, to then move that Character around. It's also worth noting that
you would need a Controller, you know, when I say it's like the brain, you would need a Controller
for a Pawn that is an AI entity, for example. The AI entity doesn't, you know, it's just
almost like a meat sack if you think about it. Without the brain, the Pawn will just be there
and it'll exist in the world, but it won't know how to navigate the world. Again, if it's
an AI entity you need to add a Controller to a Pawn to make that aware of the navigation and
anything that it needs to react with in gameplay. So hopefully that gives you a nice overview of
what the relationship between Pawn and Character is. Again, Pawn is a higher level entity and then
Character takes some of these assumptions that they think you might just want to put into a
Character and so more often than not you might just want to start with a Character class
and then thinking about controllers in general and also player controllers is a helpful kind of way
to differentiate all this. Whereas the game mode, it gets into something a little bit different here.
So the game mode is a primary class that specifies what other classes are used in the
gameplay. So you only have one game mode per level, you control the game mode via the world
settings. So if you're unsure where the world settings are, if you just open your editor,
go to window and select world settings. You might already have this open as a docked window,
but that's where you'll set your game mode. And when you set your game mode you'll see that
it has other classes that it wants to specify. Think about the game mode almost like a wrapper
for your other things. So you might set the game mode and within the game mode you might want
to say okay what kind of character do I have? What kind of controller do I have? What kind of
HUD do I have? And it kind of provides these commonly used gameplay framework classes to kind
of wrap everything into a single game type. And this will then be used for rules of the game,
maybe making a catch the flag game or something like this. This will then define what type of
gameplay you have in this level, and again you've got one per level on the game mode side.
The game instance actually persists across levels which is really useful to think about.
So if you're going from level one to level two and you have ten gold coins in level one
and then you want to go into level two, but if you just loaded level two and you had your game
coins stored on the first level, level two would forget about those game coins. Whereas having a game
instance now because it persists across levels it allows you to actually save some information
in there such as you know gold coins or lives of the player or something like this
and that will then persist. So the game instance is only ever one spawned at runtime
but it also persists across multiple levels so this is really useful
to think about and it's worth noting the game instance just can't be deleted or replaced at
runtime. There's one game as soon as you hit play in your editor the game instance spawns
and you've only got that one game instance across levels so just keep that in mind.
Now we highlighted some of these in blue because they can be associated with a networked or
replicated versions of the game mode so just keep that in mind but essentially the game
state contains data and logic relevant to all the players in the game. It might hold your team
scores or objectives or any anything that you might need for a networked multiplayer game.
So the game mode is only present on the server in a networked multiplayer context so that's worth
keeping in mind there. And the player state so if we have the game state now we have the
individual player state and that just handles the data and logic relevant to the associated
player so you know it might hold your health and your ammo count and again it primarily exists
to be leveraged in the networked multiplayer so if you're just making a non-networked game
you could use the game instance to store some of this information and that would be completely
fine. So the information on the player state you know it can just exist locally but also
on the server as well so just keep this this kind of framework in mind as you're picking which
states to use. And the hud this is less used now so you may not use the hud class as much.
The hud is the base object for displaying elements on the screen and any human controlled
player which is assigned through the game mode like I said so two up from hud we have game mode
we actually do store the hud on the game mode but yeah like I said it is often replaced with
something called UMG widgets which UMG stands for unreal motion graphics if you want to explore
that topic further and it allows you to create hud elements which you could store on the player
character or even on the level so hud is less used and it can be difficult to leverage
for anything more complicated or modular but the class exists there it's worth knowing about
but maybe you'll get less utilization from this. And similarly with the camera the camera
represents the player's point of view or how the player sees the world so you know cameras
only really have the relevance to the human control players and we can actually add cameras
to the character for example so a character blueprint by default will come with a character
a camera component so the camera class doesn't necessarily have to be used it's worth noting
though that actors can have multiple cameras so if you have your character and you want to
add a camera component to that character you could have a third person camera attached to that
and a first person and a top down all in the same character so the player view isn't constrained
to just the pawn that they have currently possessed it can be your view can be assigned to
anywhere in the game that has a camera component the camera is connected via the controller
so if you're ever trying to set the view of a character you have to do that via the controller
so this is a lot to get into i don't want to overwhelm you too much but say you had
a character in a level and we know that that character has a controller because we said the
controller is the brain that controls the character so the controller needs to receive input
so say you want to assign a new camera to the character maybe you have a fixed camera game
and maybe have a camera in the corner of the room or something you have to get the player
controller first to then set the new camera target rather than going directly through the
character so it's worth keeping that stuff in mind and we'll get into examples in the workshop
of all of these classes i just wanted to give you a very very high level overview of what
each class does and what situation it might be used in again the theory is fine if you don't have
it all completely locked down because when you get up and running unreal unreal does a lot of the
heavy lifting for you but for those people that want to know a little bit more about what
the classes and the frameworks mean hopefully that has been helpful for you so it's also worth
noting that there are two classes that technically aren't part of the gameplay framework but it's
very useful to know about so we mentioned the world settings in the previous slide and um
what we haven't touched upon is a level blueprint as well so starting with the world settings
just because we mentioned that on the previous slide the world settings panel is where we can
set an override level specific settings so each level has its own world settings
and you can use the panel to set your game mode like the example that we used in the previous
slide we said that the game mode has to be set in the world settings but also the world settings
hold global illumination values so the world settings is technically working like an actor
although you you don't get access to it at runtime the base class used for the world
settings can be set through project settings but then it would apply globally across your
entire game so again just think about the world settings as using being used to define the game
mode for a specific level but it's only relevant to that persistent level and we'll get into
you know persistent and non-persistent levels in a little while whereas the level blueprint is
it's almost like a specialized type of blueprint that acts on the level itself so each level that
you have will have its own blueprint connected with it and um again level blueprints are
technically typing an actor but they are connected directly to the level that you are
currently working on so why would i use a level blueprint so what we try to recommend is using
blueprints to create logic is a great way to go and you can create blueprints from your content
browser and bring them into your map and generally speaking it's best to do the majority
of your scripting in the the blueprints in the content browser and then drag them in
rather than scripting on your level blueprint now why is this so if i made a door and i made
the door open and close when the player gets to it but i had this door on the level blueprint
for example the door would still work fine and that's great but if i changed levels now that
door is on the previous level that i was just working on and now i don't have access to that
door that open and closes so of course i can make that second door open and close again
but i may have to copy and paste the values i may have to make sure everything's right
but what if i change the timing of that door now on level one the timing would be different
on level two and you just get inconsistency and it's repetitive work and unnecessary and say
you had a bug in the door on level one well then you'd have to go and fix it in level two
and it just gets a bit repetitive doesn't it so you might create that door blueprint in your
content browser and drag out that door into the world and therefore you have one door to rule
them all and if you need to make changes you can you can change it on the content browser
version of the blueprint and of course each blueprint would be instant so you can make
small tweaks to each door and that's a that's a good workflow to work with so generally you
wouldn't want to script on the level blueprint for something like that but if there is definitely
just some level specific logic that you need to script that level blueprint is there to
add some level specific behavior if needed